I'll be going right over reach my name
all right what the [ __ ]
chill chill chill come down come down
come down you've come
what the hell let me do my intro man hey
man hey welcome back to freakin is that
a tooth can't punch it
ah welcome back to doom
let's get supplies it's unlocked what am
i go and get it way up here ah thank you
gentlemen
I'll just go up here and expect
nothing's the only ones still alive
you're a brother believe I found you
yeah what's up something happened
what I ain't been my panting it's not my
pain I don't trust you man real please
all right don't worry Roland I'll get
you a helmet all right how do i okay
probably better fising Wow I don't trust
this I don't touch those I don't trust
it's not impressive I don't purchase
what am I supposed to go then
Oh in here all right we're good
you let it huh I'm so fun actually
minute
all right what do we have here what was
that oh [ __ ] my life
I won't do to you - not to ban you
actually all right I got some PDA I need
to turn down the census rocking out of
control
well I mean shoot maybe I killed
something
Marit armor shines I have no idea what
the [ __ ] I don't trust you for one
second
push Rudolf Runa I'm on your side
brother trick him there bath off Mars
stop shooting me Oh ten shots though
alright let's check what's going on in
here
god damn what alright that was my escape
stupids seriously it should not be doing
that set is away that means you
shouldn't ride alright what it's gone
Oh what there hey station locked ACO
card I got the coke are my orders over I
don't know specialist Wilson this is
sergeant Kelly station son look your
last known RP and fortify your position
looks like I'm trying to click it and I
keep shooting it alright the station
unlocked let's go here let's got here
okay there we go
stop stop stop I'm getting pet you're
pissing yeah man
you're pissing YouTube not the bad I
mentioned yeah way
ah straight out oh he threw it on now I
remember
hey back up back up
you don't have a face you can't be my
friend I just have it I'm sorry
back up
I keep telling them back off but you
know right where you are you know you
are right right
does it hurt that's it heart become a
woman oh you don't even have a head what
the [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
alright here we go just [ __ ] die
holy [ __ ] alright what are we going dry
cleaner like zooms no yellow
whoa whoa whoa whoa the [ __ ] down whoa
[ __ ] down whoa all right
sneak up on this [ __ ] I tried it why
did I do what I do when I'm under a
termite oh man oh man oh man oh man
don't think up on Peapod
I learned it said your friend who's your
friend
why haven't you introduced us oh [ __ ]
brother
here stop stop please stop
what's it buddy Wow I don't want to know
hey fatty hi-yah
stop I'm mad I'm done I'm done I'm not
playing with you guys you guys okay he's
the one doing the belittle oh don't
shoot me don't shoot me ah Wow okay God
hi ba gang-rape York okay we're good
we're good now the fatty stay down
dad don't give me breaks I need health
as bad as [ __ ] all right Kat don't find
me please where
now [ __ ] dick shot nipple shot oh no no
no no not today not today not today not
today not today not today not today not
today not today no sir I don't guys wall
hike we're gonna ain't need no why
all right we save here we actually
forgot to say infirmary that sounds nice
thank you Jesus speaking of religion
someone comment on my video I'm
Christian you're a Satanist you will
burn in hell
okay Christians in Christianity seems
like a nice religion just take it like
what the [ __ ] did I do
whoa naked people
Hey put on some pants my butt cancer is
laughing you ready sir
stop son I'm the one slapping people
usually it's not another how are you
fighting on the same I hate you
that's how I roll [ __ ] holy [ __ ] they
do a lot of damage I hate them I hate
those up my hate justice that's not a
word
oh I I don't trust anything in this game
I don't trust you okay I trust you don't
trust you
got to you don't worry I'm pretty all
right I'm sorry
it's not a spine what why would you keep
that in there why are you burning now
well not anymore
I am ass elevator all right you got to
make sure they're all dead all right
good
what do we have in here nothing not yeah
I can I
oh I bet it all right what do we have in
here no don't open today say only ones
PDA of bill
Tyson see your gold sir wait a second
all right
I mean a boxer all right
don't shoot him all right
did you like it why what's up
I can't believe you're still alive okay
post here
here's reports at the entire base from
Delta central authorities out with other
marine teams your mission to link up
with Bravo Team and get that
transmission sentence okay I had to ward
out the labs I'll try it this way to
find them huh I'll update your PDA
security clearance okay just keep
talking to me good job yeah thanks I
can't go there we got security upgrade
does that mean we can go in here now I
need a password
okay and that's where we came from isn't
that fantastic
well what the [ __ ] all right let's check
the PDA join up with Bravo alpha labs
and go through an immunization all right
cool side all my user data data what is
this why you know Alvin let's reel of
you does that mean I have to go in here
because I mean there's only guns here
hey been going back I think I'm going
back I punch you
yes I could but it's your low and green
and [ __ ] here what's here am I supposed
to that
punch it louder we are going in all
right other than what you think I tell
you all right don't shoot don't shoot
don't shoot
[ __ ] all right shotgun is pretty good
at those I'll keep that in mind I've
been here haven't I that's why is he
back there makes no sense I shot that
laptop I remember al is this doom
ception this is what they were talking
about
it's Kim so [ __ ] Ari alright not
doing anything stupid here alright this
got a bit no wait that's right alright
this gotta be it
yes yes progress yeah
don't shoot they never listen now you
must die
sorry about that nope
Chuck Chuck I'm alright I know you're do
that
hey I'm not no no no no there we go
that's how I roll
I keep hearing
kitchen where are the ladies oh this is
what what are you doing with that
flashlight I have one chair we can be
flashlight buddy like I just kidding
okay I know I know I know I know don't
shoot me
those are so dangerous there's so mean -
I don't know what they want from me all
right Wow
time just flies by when you're playing
them I mean I gotta tell you but anyway
we're gonna see is here to help you
psychological services Jude yeah you did
that all right
-
come on hey I know you're taking a [ __ ]
in there ah alright nothing well that is
a [ __ ] I mean the [ __ ] is that why would
you throw a leg in a toilet no sorry
that is a [ __ ]
that's nice all right I'm done cleaning
for today what the [ __ ]
thank you very much enjoy subscribe to
come ready and I'll see you next episode
or whatever see awesome brothers share
ever because I broke the other one
recipes out there missing cherry this is
my billboard I like to have a billboard
because I like to keep my thoughts on
somewhere otherwise I don't get anything
done I also have a lamp I thought it was
necessary to lit it up to show you that
it's actually working